Narrator: We celebrate
the risk‐takers...
Why not quit the job
and go for it?
...the idea‐makers...
We can really change
the world together.
[ Screams ]
Narrator: ...the ones who
determine their own fate.
‐Whoo!
‐We got a deal!
Narrator:
We celebrate entrepreneurs.
I want y'all to think ‐‐
Who's next?
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
And tonight, Rohan Oza,
the branding guru behind
some of the world's most
successful consumer products,
joins the Tank.
I'm looking on
"Shark Tank"
for the next
billion‐dollar exit.
You think that you can put
the fear of God in Elon Musk?
Yes, I think we have
the potential to do that.
And we have the sales
to prove it.
I wouldn't
play with fire.
We've got battle‐tested IP.
Why do I not like it?
Because you're not
a millennial.
Oh!
Whoa!
♪♪
Narrator:
First into the Tank
is an accessory
for the tech generation.
♪♪
Hi. My name is Joe Croft.
I'm from
San Clemente, California.
And I'm here asking for $750,000
in exchange for 5%
of my company, Gunnar Optiks.
♪♪
Sharks, we live in a world
dominated by screens ‐‐
phones, computers, tablets, PCs.
You're probably staring at a
screen six to eight hours a day.
At the end of a long day,
your eyes might feel
a little bit like this.
Like they're covered in sand.
[ Laughter ]
Corcoran: Oh, God.
Or perhaps
they're dry and irritated
because they take a pounding.
Oh!
Or maybe you've got
a burning sensation
from all that harsh blue light.
[ Laughing ]
Oh, God.
Or maybe you just have
a headache that won't go away.
[ Laughs ]
Computer eye strain has become
the number‐one
health‐related office complaint
in the United States,
outstripping carpal tunnel
by 40 to 1.
Wow.
And all those screens
aren't going away anytime soon.
So what's the solution?
Enter Gunnar Optiks.
Ta‐dum.
Eyewear for a digital age.
Our patented optical technology
is the only
clinically proven solution
for relieving
all four major symptoms
of computer eye strain.
Gunnar can help prevent
dry eyes,
reduce muscular eye fatigue,
fight against glare,
and, very importantly,
scientifically proven
to reduce
that harmful blue light
emitted from those screens
by 65%.
Using our eyewear,
you'll find an increase
in optical clarity, focus,
and visual performance.
So hopefully, those long days at
work don't feel quite so long.
So, Sharks, let's make headaches
and digital eye fatigue
a thing of the past.
In a world where screens are
never more than a few feet away,
the need to protect your eyes
has never been so clear.
♪♪
So, I've got some samples here
to pass out.
Good.
♪♪
Lovely.
Ah.
Here you go.
Thank you.
♪♪
For you.
Thank you.
There you go.
Thank you,
sir.
And for you.
Corcoran:
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Joe.
And for you.
Thank you very much.
So, as you hold that out in
the computer‐viewing distance,
you'll see
that the contrast is enhanced.
Yeah,
there's a difference.
You'll also
feel your eyes relax.
It blocks
the blue light, correct?
Absolutely.
In fact, we've
scientifically measured it.
We block 65% of the blue light
that's emitted
from all those screens.
So, yellow light
is more calming
and better
for the eyes?
So, there's a lot of science
that goes into
why yellow light is much better
and why blue light,
which is very close
to the UV part of the spectrum,
is high energy
and is actually damaging to you
and can disrupt
your sleep patterns.
So, let's get
right into the business.
Tell us about
your sales.
There's gonna be a lot of sales
with a $16 million valuation.
Last year, we sold $6.5 million
worth of eyewear.
Greiner: Wow.
Good for you.
Wow.
I like it.
What about this year?
This year, we're trending
towards $7.5 million.
We are approaching
60% gross margin.
That's great.
What's the average
price point?
The average price point
right now is around 60 to 80.
And are you making money,
and if so, how much?
The answer is yes.
And?
Last year, EBITDA was 500,000.
You're doing a 60% margin,
which is great.
But you only made
half a million EBITDA.
Where ‐‐
Where's the cost going?
So, we are going to
build a brand.
We have penetrated
into the gaming category.
I was thinking for gamers,
this would be ‐‐
Absolutely.
In fact ‐‐
That's where your strength
has been, right?
Gaming is where
you basically deliver this?
With the gaming crowd,
we sponsor
a number of e‐sports athletes.
E‐sports is the wild West
right now.
Do you have a patent?
That is a great question
because we not only
have a patent,
we've got battle‐tested IP.
We have gone toe to toe
with some of the largest people
in the industry out there.
We've gone into the courtroom
and come out victorious.
Joe,
does it have to be ‐‐
Joe, what's your experience
in the eyewear business?
I spent a formative part
of my career at Oakley,
which,
as you guys probably know,
dominates the, uh,
performance category of sports.
How much
did you raise?
We, over the course of the
company, have raised $9 million.
Oh!
Greiner: Wow.
There, the rock
just got dropped there.
How much do you owe?
Me personally, at 20%.
Okay.
What happened
to the rest?
As you raise, you dilute.
You've had to continue
to raise money.
That means
something didn't work.
We really have only raised money
in two large tranches.
So we haven't raised any money
for the last several years.
The company is profitable,
right?
And ‐‐
Okay, well,
good for you.
That's a good step.
A‐Absolutely.
If you can give the numbers,
it might help.
Just rapidly
what your revenue has been.
Last year, 6.5.
The year prior,
we were $8 million.
$8 million?
Correct.
And the year prior
was about the same.
What are you gonna use
the money for?
Marketing.
That's a‐a key thing.
We need to get the exposure out.
We are evangelists about how bad
people's eyes are becoming.
So, then,
you must have debt.
We do have debt.
How much?
How much debt?
Uh, 1.2.
Ooh.
Wow.
Joe, when I see
an entrepreneur
who has 20% stake
in the business,
I stop looking at them
as an entrepreneur, honestly.
I‐I think of them as an employee
with an incentive.
It makes me feel
very uncertain.
♪♪
I'm out.
Okay.
I'm in
the computer business.
I work with com‐‐
300 computer, geeky guys.
I will buy them
anything they want.
We look at screens
24 hours a day, 7 days a week,
for some of the biggest
companies in the world.
No one has ever
come to me and said,
"My gosh, I need
a pair of yellow glasses."
You've raised $9 million.
There's just a lot of
uncertainty for me.
Sorry.
I'm out.
You deserve
a lot of credit.
A ton of credit
because you are
an eyewear‐industry survivor.
There's not
a lot of those.
But in looking
for an investment,
I'm not looking
for a survivor.
I'm looking
for a thriver, right?
Ooh.
It's not obvious to me
that you know exactly how
you're going to use the money.
What we do need to do is go from
a niche marketed product,
which is strictly
in the gaming space ‐‐
we need to get out
into the mainstream.
We need to go QVC.
We need to talk to ‐‐
But you did. No, see,
you're making my point, right?
Okay.
You're bouncing, bouncing,
pivoting, pivoting, pivoting,
looking for something
to take you to the next level,
but you don't know
what that is yet.
And because you don't know
what that answer is,
I have to say I'm out.
♪♪
Look, I'm torn
'cause...
I love the brand.
I like you.
You've got the energy.
You've got the passion.
And I think you have
a brand name here
that can
truly be built.
But what I do well
is I add fuel to growth brands,
and as much as I love
your passion,
I feel that
the time has been there
to take this brand into channels
that would've caught.
And much as my heart is saying,
"Jump in with the guy,"
my gut from a financial
standpoint is reticent,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
♪♪
Good luck, Joe.
Croft: All right.
No, there's me.
No, Lori's left.
[ Chatter ]
I never ‐‐
I didn't go out.
Wow.
♪♪
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out,
and Lori is Joe's last chance
at a deal
for his computer‐safe
eyewear company, Gunnar Optiks.
When you put
those glasses on,
two things
I noticed happened.
One, that irritating blue light
is gone.
Two, it's much clearer,
and it's almost like
the letters get bigger
and more defined.
Very interesting to me
because I have sold
a product called Neox,
Neox sunglasses.
I've sold probably
$30 million worth of them.
My concern here is that
you have a lot of debt.
You don't have
a lot of equity.
I see a solution.
I see the solution is
I do feel TV is what you need.
You need
the demonstration
because once you look
through them, you're sold.
I'm gonna give you
a flier,
but it's going to
be this.
Wow.
I'm going to give you
$375,000 as an investment,
$375,000 as a loan
at 8%,
for...8%.
Hey, I‐I ‐‐
And I'll try
to blow it up for you.
That's a no‐brainer.
Croft:
That ‐‐ That is amazing.
I love the fact that we have
an offer on the table, and ‐‐
The only offer
on the table.
That is the only offer
Herjavec: [ Laughs ]
I feel confident
that I can sell these.
Good.
And I know you can.
Out of respect
to our current investment base,
because just like you would
want me to care for your money,
I need to care for the money
of our current investors.
Taking that much of the company
would be tough
for those current investors.
What if I gave you the 750K
all as a loan at 8%
and I take 5%?
Listen.
I see me
as a great lifeline for you
because you need
awareness.
You really need
You know your margins.
We know our margins,
absolutely.
So you know how much more
you have to sell
to pay back
the $750,000.
That 750K coming in
is beautiful.
We love it.
The equity slice just seems
a little bit rich.
I'd love to counter with 2.5%
on the equity slice.
Ooh.
Wow.
2.5?
You came in here
offering 5.
Exactly,
5 for 750 straight...
You can't go backwards.
...str‐straight equity.
You're dealing with
one of
the biggest brand builders
in America here.
And we know that.
We respect that.
I wouldn't
nickel‐and‐dime it.
Like, you want to go from
6 to 60, not from 6 to 7.
I wouldn't
play with fire.
The 2.5%
is just so small.
Is there somewhere
in the middle there?
Are you really gonna do that
for just 2.5%?
I wouldn't
nickel‐and‐dime it.
Your dilution
is minimal.
Yeah.
Again, I‐I ‐‐ I'm ‐‐
I'm asking the question
'cause we really want
to get a deal done,
and quite frankly ‐‐
Then say yes to the 5%
if you really want to do a deal.
Say yes.
The only reason I mentioned
the equity is with that growth
and, again, being in a space
where there's a ton
of imminent activity ‐‐
Joe, you're in danger
of losing
the one deal
you have on the table.
The equity ‐‐ H‐Hold on.
We're ‐‐ We're having
a nice discussion.
Lori ‐‐
Joe, you're gonna lose
this discussion.
[ Chatter ]
Joe, Joe,
I can't do the 2.5%.
Take my deal.
Are we up to ‐‐ How about 4%?
I don't want to ‐‐
Wow!
Joe.
You're nickeling‐and‐diming.
My hand is out.
♪♪
All right,
let's go ahead and do it.
Yes?
Let's go ahead and do a deal.
Corcoran: Yes!
Greiner:
All right. All right.
Here we go.
Mazel tov.
Corcoran: Wow.
Good.
All right,
this should be fun.
It's a great product.
It is
a great product.
And we just need
awareness.
It's a great product.
Congrats.
Congratulations, Joe.
Oza:
♪♪
When it came down
to the actual deal on the table,
it got very, very real.
You're taking money
that's real dollars.
This is real investors that are
gonna be affected by it.
That's when I started to sweat.
But at the end of the day,
we got the deal done.
[ Sighs deeply ]
I think my blood pressure's
coming down just a little bit.
♪♪
Narrator: In season 6,
Sara and Josh Margulis
made a deal with Kevin O'Leary
for their online
honeymoon registry, Honeyfund.
Mr. O'Leary,
you have a deal.
Wow.
What a surprise.
I think you made
a wise decision.
Greiner: Wow.
Let's see
what they're up to now.
♪♪
Josh: "Shark Tank" has been
a whirlwind.
We're working
harder than ever,
but we have more opportunities
than we had before.
Hey, Bruce.
How are ya?
Hello.
Welcome to Target.
Thank you very much.
Sara: About
a year and a half ago,
Target called us
to talk about
honeymoon giving
on their wedding registry site,
and we're so thrilled to be here
to finalize things today.
We want to stay
ahead of the curve,
and this
is the opportunity
to create
a cutting‐edge experience.
A guest will come on
to the website.
They'll see Honeyfund
plus Target.
They'll be able to click in
to one of the experiences,
like honeymoon travel,
and then they're gonna be able
to add it
directly to their registry.
This is a dream deal
for Target and for Honeyfund.
You combine the traditional
registry business,
things like sheets
and plates and knives,
along with
what Honeyfund offers ‐‐
travel and experiences
that millennials want to buy.
You put them together,
it's huge.
We're really excited
about this opportunity.
The biggest obstacle we face
to growing our brand
is competition.
Being part
of Target's wedding registry
will help
Honeyfund reach
potentially millions
of new customers.
Josh: The year
leading up to our pitch,
we had done $987,000
in revenue.
It's been three years
since "Shark Tank."
We've now done
$5.6 million.
O'Leary: Think about
the Honeyfund journey.
They're sitting on their sofa,
dreaming up an online business.
They come on "Shark Tank."
They start growing,
and now we're sitting
in Target's headquarters,
integrating
with their online registry.
It just doesn't get any better.
Sara:
Now more and more couples
will receive the gift
of their dream honeymoon,
and that's what really
makes us the happiest.
This is
going to be huge.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a restaurant
dedicated to
a healthy food trend.
♪♪
[ Italian accent ] So, Sharks,
my name is Alessandro,
and I'm the co‐founder
of Avocaderia.
I am seeking $300,000 in
exchange for 10% of my company.
Wow.
Growing up in Italy,
as you might have guessed,
I always had access
to healthy and fresh food.
When I moved to the U. S.,
I realized that, uh, you know,
people were becoming
more and more aware
about what they were eating,
and healthy food
was not just an option.
It was a priority for them.
Unfortunately, the alternatives
were pretty bland.
I kept running into
the same few options
of the so‐called healthy
but frivolous meals.
So one day,
I decided to make myself
one of those famous
avocado toast,
and, man, it was delizioso.
[ Laughs ]
So, what really got me
is that avocados are the perfect
match between healthy and tasty.
That's how the idea
for Avocaderia was born.
Of course, every item
on our menu contains ‐‐
you guessed it ‐‐ avocados.
[ Laughter ]
We offer a seasonal
rotating menu,
composed of toast,
salads and bowls, and smoothies.
Our current top seller ‐‐
also my favorite ‐‐
is the Mediterranean toast,
a warm, savory toast
made with olive tapenade,
avocado mash,
cherries and ripe tomatoes...
Ah!
...feta, and pistachio dukkah.
Yes, it's really good.
Oh, my God.
All our dishes are designed
to look as good as they taste.
So, Sharks,
we are ripe for success.
Are you ready to take your bite?
All: Yes.
Perfect.
I love your accent.
I'm in.
Herjavec: Andiamo!
[ Laughter ]
So, you are
without feta...
Okay, perfect.
...because I was told
you prefer without.
You are
a smart man.
[ Light laughter ]
Yours is with feta.
Yes.
Enjoy.
Thank you.
It's amazing.
I'm gonna tell you what ‐‐
what's on that, as well.
I'm hungry.
Greiner: Oh, my God.
So good.
Yours is also
without feta.
Yes, sir.
There you go.
Corcoran: Mm.
Nicely presented. Thank you.
Herjavec: Oh,
that looks fancy.
Appreciate it.
Enjoy.
Grazia.
Prego.
It's a pleasure.
Hey!
Oh, it's good.
That is really,
really good.
The Mediterranean toast?
Corcoran: Mmm.
It's really good.
Alessandro:
So, what ‐‐ what you're sampling
is, uh, the Mediterranean toast.
The other one is the beet toast,
which is a vegan option.
It's made with beet hummus,
a slice of avocado,
arugula, and spice seeds.
That's terrific,
as well.
And then ‐‐ [ Laughs ]
And then
we have the mango smoothie,
and finally,
the chocolate mousse,
which is also
a vegan chocolate mousse.
It doesn't contain any milk,
so...
With avocado?
Of course. Everything ‐‐
Corcoran:
Is this how you ‐‐
Is this how you present
your meals at the restaurant?
That's correct.
Beautifully presented.
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
A restaurant right now because
we are inside the food hall.
We're in a very cool space,
uh, in Sunset Park in Brooklyn.
So, how long
have you been in business?
We started five months ago.
What did you do this last month
in business?
Uh, we did $75,000.
How much did it cost you
to open the store?
Uh, we invested about $70,000
in total.
Oh, that's great.
Because we were able ‐‐
Do you have any photos
of the restaurant
that we could see?
Of course, we have some photos.
So, this is the outside.
The branding for us
is very important.
We have neon lights...
It's cute.
...because we wanted the place
to be very alive,
to make people that work inside
happy to be there.
You know, it's not
another chain, you know.
Corcoran:
That looks yummy.
You know, like,
another place ‐‐
That ‐‐
I'd like one of those.
How much
is the toast?
So, the ‐‐ all ‐‐ all our prices
vary from $6 to $14,
so the price point
is made to be affordable.
Alessandro,
what's your background?
Are you a food guy
or are you a design guy?
I was born in ‐‐
So, I was born in Tuscany,
grew up in Modena,
and then I worked
in a public investment bank
for about one year,
then I moved to consulting.
Realized it was not for me,
and so last year, I moved to ‐‐
to Seattle because I was
managing a new company,
and I really felt
it was really hard for me
to find good food to eat
every single day,
you know, and, uh,
so I'm actually not the ‐‐
the best chef out there,
even though I'm Italian,
so I should be, but...
[ Laughs ]
...I started making myself
this avocado toast,
and I fell in love
because you know what?
It made me feel very healthy,
and by the same time,
they're very filling because
avocado is a fatty fruit, yes.
So, like, what's the plan
here? We're gonna ‐‐ multiples,
are you gonna franch‐‐
Like,
what's the game plan?
Yes, absolutely.
So, we're already opening
a second one
in, uh, in Chelsea in New York.
In a food court,
as well?
Correct.
And, uh, the idea is for us
to open 20 locations
directly owned
in the next five years.
Cuban:
How much does this ‐‐
How much money do you need
to open 20 locations?
So, uh, basically,
for each location,
we estimate an average
of about $200,000.
But you opened the last one
for $70,000.
Correct
because that's in a food hall.
So,
for an independent restaurant,
we need $200,000 because half
of that is for the build now.
Okay, but you're looking
for $300,000.
That's correct.
We want to open
one independent restaurant
and one in a food hall.
The food hall
are cheaper for us.
So that takes care
of the $300,000.
Correct.
Where are you
gonna get the money
to open up
the other 20?
So, the idea is to ‐‐
gross sales ‐‐
we're projecting
to close this year at $750,000
as we open the second place.
Next year, we, of course,
are planning to do $4.3 million,
and at that point...
What?!
...the idea...
How does that happen
so quickly?
We are already opening the
second one with our own money,
so we already put ourselves
$170,000 of our own savings.
Why is it worth
$3 million...
Yes.
...today
with one location?
So, we are already
making profit.
We received about 50 requests
for franchising already.
We're not planning
to do that yet.
Also we have a deal
for a cookbook,
which is actually
in the six figures.
You already have
that money?
Correct.
We're using that to open ‐‐
to finance a second location.
Are you planning to open
all these in the New York area?
Yes.
The idea is to open ‐‐
is to open the first locations
all in the New York area,
then the other target cities
are L. A., San Diego,
Miami, and, uh, Texas, as well,
so those are the ‐‐
You know, um, I have to say,
this was delicious.
And I think
it's a really great mission
to have healthy food.
My only problem with it
is one thing.
Everything has to be
about avocados.
And I like avocados.
Yep.
But I'm not
a huge avocado fan.
And for that reason solely,
I am out.
I appreciate that.
Thank you so much.
So, Alessandro, you've done
an amazing job. I love the menu.
I love
everything of it.
But the valuation for me
is not $3 million.
I can't argue
with your accent.
[ Chuckles ]
I'm out today.
Thank you, Robert.
I appreciate that.
Great idea.
We'll wait for you
in New York.
[ Laughs ]
Oza: You have, um,
amazing energy,
a great vibe,
all very good.
I‐I want to jump in.
Yes.
Like, I'm leaning
to jump in.
I think my problem
is very similar to Lori,
is the entire menu
is avocado‐based.
So the minute I get
a little avocado‐fatigued...
Yep.
...which is ‐‐
happens to me
in food and beverage
all the time...
Right.
...I'm out.
And so then
I'm not coming back
because the variety isn't there
for things non‐avocado.
Yep.
So even though I love you
and it's very catchy,
for that reason,
I'm out.
♪♪
I happen to think, uh,
the greatness to your business
is it is single‐minded
in its focus.
I‐I'm shocked to hear
anyone doesn't like avocado.
Everyone I know
loves avocado.
You slam it on everything,
they're happy.
The dishes
you produced here
totally taste different
from each other.
They were great.
That chocolate pudding,
like, blew me away.
And you know what?
You are particularly good
at design, as well,
which is at least a third
of the business right there.
So I'm going to
make you an offer.
Thank you.
And I'm gonna make it
with my partner here ‐‐ Mark.
Very chatty.
Wow!
$300,000 for 25%.
♪♪
Well, first of all,
thank you so much for the offer.
Uh, definitely,
it has great value,
the fact that both of you
would be in.
Um, at the same time, we think
we are at the very early stage,
and we think we can really
grow this up a lot.
And we ‐‐ we feel like we don't
want to give out so much of it
at this point.
So, would you be willing
to go down to 15%?
No,
I would think not.
♪♪
Here's what happens.
We all have large portfolios.
We get up in the morning.
Everybody's calling.
The ones
we're excited about
are the ones we're deeply
vested in, so picture that.
Mark's gonna jump up
and return your call for 7.5%,
as I am?
No, I don't think so.
You have to have more than that
to be enthusiastic.
It would be unfair
to you.
♪♪
Would you put $200,000 each
and go at 20%?
So $200,000 for 10% each?
♪♪
Yeah, we give up
a little bit more money,
but we get
the percentage we want.
I would do that.
Okay,
I'm good with that.
Deal.
Good job.
Awesome.
Herjavec:
There you go!
Oza:
Go, avocados!
Thank you so much.
Yeah!
Greiner: Good one.
It was great, man.
It's a pleasure.
Thank you so much.
Congratulations.
Great job. Terrific.
My pleasure.
Thank you so much.
Leave the food here.
Great job, Alessandro.
Thank you.
Bye‐bye. Whoo‐hoo!
Grazie. Ciao!
Greiner: Congrats.
Ssss!
[ Speaks Italian ]
I am absolutely
living the American dream
with partners like this,
and I'm sure that Barbara
would bring a lot on the table,
given their experience
in the real‐estate world,
and Mark, as well, is gonna
help us grow the business,
scale it very fast
and make it very successful.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next into the Tank
is a business that grew
out of a mission to help people.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Dr. Catlin Powers,
and my product is SolSource.
I'm here today to offer you
an exclusive deal ‐‐
3% of my company for $500,000.
Wow.
We all love fun in the sun,
those long summer days outdoors,
grilling up delicious food.
But how many times
have you gone to grill
and realized that
you're completely out of fuel
or that you have to
scrape the soot off first?
Fuel ‐‐ it's time‐consuming,
it's expensive, it's heavy,
and it leaves cancer‐causing
particles on your food.
But what if I told you
you could cook delicious food
100% fuel‐free?
Introducing SolSource,
a grill powered 100% by the sun.
Our classic SolSource model
is fast, powerful, and durable.
It heats up to 500 degrees
Fahrenheit in seconds
and can cook a meal
in just 10 minutes.
Our SolSource Sport model
features a lightweight,
compact design
that packs down
into a 2‐foot carrying case
so that you can cook anything
anywhere under the sun.
Hmm.
With SolSource,
you can save money,
save time, and save energy,
all while cooking delicious food
100% fuel‐free
and pollution‐free.
So, Sharks, who wants to power
your next barbecue
with solar energy?
Let's do it.
Yeah. [ Chuckles ]
Herjavec:
How much sun do I need,
and how long does it take
for it to get up to heat?
As long
as you can see your shadow,
you can cook with SolSource,
and it heats up five times
faster than a charcoal grill.
So, for those of us who are
grilling‐challenged, right...
Yes.
...and need a sense
of temperature and time...
Yes.
...are there
any temperature gauges at all
or any way to ‐‐
to judge the temperature?
You can add
a temperature gauge in.
We don't currently offer that
as part of the system,
but it's an easy add‐on.
But how are you knowing
and gauging ‐‐
like, when you have a gas grill,
you can see ‐‐
turn it up,
turn it down.
How do you
control that?
Is there any way
to moderate it at all?
You can moderate it down
by covering pieces of the panel.
You can moderate it up by having
additional panels on the outside
that go up and down.
Oza: Break down
the numbers for me.
What do you
sell it for?
$249 for the solar system,
$499 for the ‐‐
Are you giving us retail
or cost right now?
Retail. Retail.
Retail.
So,
$249 and how much?
$499.
We have 80% margins,
and we sell direct.
Wow.
Okay.
Oza: How did you come up
with this idea?
I mean, clearly, the doctor part
had something to do with it.
I have degrees in chemistry
and environmental health.
I got my doctoral degree
from Harvard University,
and 10 years ago,
I went up into the Himalayas
to do
a scientific research project,
and I ended up developing
this company instead.
And the reason is that
a local family
invited me into their home,
and it turned out
that the air they were breathing
in their home
was 10 times more polluted
than the air in Beijing,
simply from cooking
their afternoon meal.
What I found ‐‐ every year,
more people are dying
from smoke exposure
inside their homes
just from cooking
than AIDS and malaria combined,
4.3 million people.
No way.
Wow.
Once I learned this,
I couldn't go back
to my research as normal.
I left my research
and I started working with
the nomadic families there
to try to find a solution.
How many
have you sold to date?
So, we've done 1.3 million
in sales.
Wow.
Cuban: Okay, so,
what did you do last year?
Uh, last year,
we did 100K.
Herjavec: That's it?
So, let me tell you guys about
the trajectory of our company
over time.
Yes, please.
Okay.
We started out
up in the Himalayas.
We built a barter‐based business
because most of our customers
had no cash income,
so we bartered our solar stoves
for agricultural goods,
and we delivered by horse
and yak and motorcycle
when we needed to
in order to reach our customers.
Of course.
You're the only product
we've ever had here
that delivered by yak.
[ Chuckles ]
So, we were building
a profitable, growing business
up in the Himalayas,
and then we ran
right into the middle
of a very big problem,
which is ethnic conflict.
We had military lockdown.
Wow.
Our profit margins
dropped to negative $4 per unit.
Our team was being threatened,
so I made the very challenging,
soul‐wrenching decision
to completely change
our business model,
and ‐‐ oh, gosh ‐‐
it was probably the hardest time
that I faced in my life,
was those periods.
Uh...
Why?
Because of seeing what
our customers were going through
and knowing that there was
nothing we could do about it.
I've almost died twice
in the course of this business,
both from parasite illnesses,
so I was not doing well
from a health perspective
during that time.
Did you move
to America then?
Yes.
So, that has been the transition
that we have been in.
We've been selling
through our own website
and on Amazon, as well.
And this year,
you think you'll do...?
S‐‐ We will hit around half a
million by the end of this year.
Why the jump?
What ‐‐
What accelerated it?
Producing this product.
So this product ‐‐
When was this product released?
Last month.
It's been amazing, the response
that we've gotten from people.
This is a new reflector material
that's 92% energy‐efficient.
We have utility patents
on the designs of our product,
on our new materials
that we've developed,
but our next product
is a solar battery system.
It stores energy
in organic molecules
over multiple days at a time,
a lot like plants do.
It's a natural
biomimicry system,
and that system will allow us
to cook at night
and also cook indoors.
So, of all the things you
could do with your technology,
why a grill
when you could be changing
the world much more quickly,
harnessing the sun
to create energy?
I see
working in the consumer markets
as a way
of iterating the technology
to make it
an amazing technology...
But you realize ‐‐
...and then using it to go
to those other application.
So you're fighting
two battles then, right?
You're fighting your technology
battle for efficiency.
Mm.
And then
you're fighting
the consumer marketing side,
right?
Which is
even more expensive.
You know, it seems
you're pretty brilliant
and you take
a lot of risks.
The problem for me today
is barbecuers, they ‐‐
they are into that taste
and that smell, right?
So, for today,
I have to be out.
Thank you for that.
Herjavec: You know,
one of my favorite sayings is,
"Every time
you see a small business,
someone made
a courageous decision."
Your entire journey
is all about courage.
Mm.
But you have
an incredible technology,
yet you want
to pitch us a grill.
It makes me
not trust the presentation.
It doesn't add up for me.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Yeah. We ‐‐ We have a number
of different aspects
to our business, so when ‐‐
Corcoran: No, but hold it
right there, if I may.
Oh, yes.
You just
proved his point.
Uh, what is odd to me
is you have an answer
to everything immediately,
and it's all even.
I feel like
I'm with a robot here,
a really smart robot,
but it does leave me stressed.
There's nothing wrong with
having an answer for everything.
I ‐‐ By the way,
I'm ‐‐ I'm ‐‐ I'm fine ‐‐
I'm fine with your I. Q.
Greiner: Other people
may think that's good.
But I can say to you
I actually find it unbelievable
what you're asking
for this business.
I'm just not a believer.
I'm out.
Mm.
You know, Barbara,
I really appreciate
your perspective on that.
♪♪
What I feel here, it's like
the tail wagging the dog.
Mm‐hmm.
Mm.
You know,
you rolled in here
with a diamond
in the rough,
and you're showing us
a grill.
Had you
come in here with,
"All right, guys,
here's my technology..."
Mm.
"...demonstrated
in a grill..."
Mm.
"...but my story
is not this grill."
Mm.
"My story
is the solar‐powered battery
that will
make magic happen
and transition cities
and economies."
I would've been
all ears.
Mm.
But the problem is
now I have too many questions
on part B.
Mm.
Because we spent so much time
on the part A.
On part A.
Mm.
And so, unfortunately,
for that ‐‐
for that reason,
I'm out.
♪♪
Okay, so,
do you think you would be able
to apply this reflector system
to a car?
Yes, so, what we're looking at
right now
is microdizing these reflectors
into essentially solar skins,
so they'll be flexible, right?
So, okay,
I get it.
Yeah.
Do you think that you can put
the fear of God in Elon Musk
and put them
out of business?
Yes, I think we have
the potential to do that.
Okay, I'm in.
I'll offer you $500,000,
but I want 5%.
♪♪
How about 4% and a board seat?
Done.
All right,
Mark.
Wonderful to
work with you.
The pleasure is mine.
I'm excited about it.
Thank you.
Thanks.
She's a scientist.
She's not a businesswoman.
Look, 99.999999% of the people
who walk in that door
are not billion‐dollar
opportunities.
This one is if it's right,
no question.
Cuban:
You know what?
The worst case ‐‐
I am going to have
the best‐tasting steaks
in all of America
without using ‐‐
Oza: Oh, yeah. You're gonna have
a million‐dollar steak.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up are brothers who believe
they have a better version
of a trendy beverage.
♪♪
What's up, Sharks?
My name
is Jordan DeCicco,
and I am the founder
and youngest brother of Sunniva.
To my right
is my middle brother,
my co‐founder,
Jake DeCicco.
[ Laughs ]
To my left
is our oldest brother
and our CEO,
Jimmy DeCicco.
We grew up
in Kingston, New York,
and we created
the world's first...
super coffee.
Super coffee.
Herjavec: Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Today, we are asking for
a $500,000 investment
for a 4.5% stake
in our business.
[ Laughs ]
As college athletes,
we were always tired.
Our coaches were unhappy
because we were falling asleep
in class after morning workouts,
and our school stores
offered only the usual,
unhealthy, bottled coffees
and energy drinks.
But the three of us
refused to put that garbage
into our bodies.
We thought
that there has to be
a healthy
energy alternative.
So, in our youngest brother's
dorm room,
we brewed
something better ‐‐
organic Colombian
coffee beans
blended with 10 grams
of lactose‐free protein
and healthy fats from
coconut oil for lasting fuel.
Like that,
Super Coffee was born.
Jordan dropped out of school,
Jimmy left his job,
our poor mother
shed a few tears,
but we were determined
to share our super coffee
with the world.
Jimmy:
Over the last 18 months,
we've come a long way from
our little brother's dorm room,
and we've created
a product
that people want
because it works,
and we have the sales
to prove it.
Sharks, as athletes,
we are looking for a coach
to help us refine
our business fundamentals
and share our super coffee
with the world.
All right, guys,
let's try some super coffee.
Greiner: Yep.
Cuban:
Let's do it.
Yeah.
[ Laughs ]
Will I
feel super afterwards?
All day long.
[ Laughs ]
Okay.
Got a few options
for you guys.
You can see the flavor banners
there for each one.
I love when you give us
lots of little things to try.
Barbara.
Thank you,
my friend.
Oh, you're welcome.
Herjavec: Thank you.
So, you have
the vanilla bean,
which is
our top‐selling flavor.
Then we have
our maple hazelnut,
which is
my personal favorite,
and we have
our dark mocha,
and then an unsweetened,
sugar‐free black brew.
[ Chuckling ] Whoa.
I just had that one.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. That'll wake you up,
Rohan. That'll get you going.
The taste profile
is great.
Awesome.
I'm still getting
some back end, though.
Whoa.
What do you have
in here, stevia?
So, yeah, you get a little bit
of organic maple syrup
and then a little bit
of organic stevia.
Why do I not like it?
Because you're not
a millennial.
[ Laughter ]
Oh!
Whoa!
Bam!
Well, I'm out.
I'm out.
So, Jordan, you said you have
the sales to prove it.
Wow us.
We've done $600,000
to date.
This is just
our second year of business,
and we're gonna do $2.1 million
in sales this year.
Wow.
Corcoran: I'd like to know
how you're gonna get there.
So ‐‐ So ‐‐
You've done $600,000?
That's a big jump.
That's right.
We actually
just partnered
with the world's largest
food‐service provider,
so we're putting it
in corporate cafeterias
at offices
and on college campuses.
We're in Whole Foods.
We're in Target.
Greiner: Oh.
We're in Wegmans,
and we're in Wawa.
Wow.
How did you do that?
And then ‐‐
People love the stuff.
It's ‐‐ I mean, we're the w‐‐
So, let me step back
to food service real quick.
Yeah.
So, with the world's largest
food‐service provider...
Cuban:
Which is...
...the Compass Group.
They do
$20 billion annually,
and we signed a national
partnership with the company.
Give me, year to date,
what's your revenue been so far?
$400,000 in 150 accounts.
So in
the next six months,
you guys expect
to do $1.7 million?
Is that correct?
Yes.
So, so, guys,
my background is in beverages,
so I was involved
in vitamin water,
so, SmartWater, Bai ‐‐
All very early‐stage companies
went on to become
billion‐dollar exits,
so I'm looking
on "Shark Tank"
for the next
billion‐dollar exit.
That starts
with a few things.
Give me your margins.
How much are you making it for?
What are you
selling it for?
And where are you making this
at the moment?
Absolutely.
So, we have a 43% gross margin,
which is pretty good for ‐‐
for the beverage category.
So your cost,
your total cost to goods is...?
A dollar and 5 cents
a bottle. That's
ingredients, that's label,
that's blending, that's boxing,
pallets, all that stuff.
And then the cost?
We sell it to distributors
for $1.85.
Our price on the shelf
is $3.29.
So, $3.29 compared to
your competitor ‐‐
how much are they?
So, a Starbucks product
is gonna be right around $2.99.
Right.
And then
where we talk about
this new,
enhanced category.
This is really
what makes us different.
If you see products
that are using the protein
and the coconut oil
and butter,
those products
on the shelf at Whole Foods
that are, like, cold‐pressed,
are gonna be $4.99 to $7.99.
Cuban:
You found a niche, right?
It's like, okay,
we're gonna be cheaper,
we're gonna be healthier,
we're gonna be sweet but
relatively low‐calorie, right?
Exactly.
Yep.
Cuban: To play
towards millennial.
I get that, but let's talk about
the cash required.
How much
have you guys raised?
We've raised
$1.3 million,
most recently
at a $7 1/2 million valuation.
Okay.
Okay, so, I'm in investor
in Bulletproof Coffee.
It's one of the most
iconic coffees out there.
I'm keen to try and ‐‐
I don't have to
just do Bulletproof.
But what are you guys doing
that's breaking through
that's a real
category‐changer?
Because I see some of
these things out there already.
Exactly, Rohan. So, so,
Bulletproof is a ‐‐ a
little bit different target,
I would say,
a little bit older audience.
For us, if ‐‐
if you're looking at
the R. T. D. coffee space
right now,
95% of it is Starbucks.
That's it.
There's not
a lot of competition out there,
but it is
the fastest‐growing category
in beverage space
right now.
If you ask
a lot of our consumers,
they're seeing something
that's affordable,
that they like,
that they like the taste,
only 7 grams of sugar
from organic maple syrup.
So, guys, you ‐‐
you've ‐‐ you've done
$400,000 year to date.
That's right.
Oza: I know you got a lot
of new accounts coming on.
But as my venerable Sharks here
have taught me over time,
that's yet to come.
We'd like to know
what's in the bank today.
So,
$400,000 so far.
And if my rudimentary math
is right,
you're looking to give away
5% for $500,000.
Is that right?
That's right.
4.5.
So you're putting
a $10 million valuation
on a company that's done
$400,000 this year.
That's right.
Yeah, but ‐‐
Oza: By the way,
and I've been part
of some
ridiculous valuations,
and this is sporty
even by my standard.
No, I understand,
but we're not a mature company.
We're not Bai.
Bai got acquired
for 6X,
their ‐‐ their revenue
at $275 billion.
But that's the point.
You're not.
We're just getting started,
and that's why we're here.
We have the inventory.
We have the accounts.
We need your money
to hire sales reps
and get this product
out there.
But that value, guys.
Talk to me. I mean ‐‐
If ‐‐
Ro, if we do $2 million,
if we do $2.1 million
in revenue this year,
you guys are getting a deal,
and we are going to ‐‐
Yeah, but if I was
four inches taller, I'd
clean up, but that's ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
That's an "if."
Jimmy: It's not an "if."
The distribution is there.
If we don't add
another account,
we're gonna do
$800,000 in sales this year.
We just added Target.
We added Wegmans.
We added Wawa.
You know,
I've invested in
two different beverage companies
on "Shark Tank,"
and I've never seen my money
go out the door faster
and never come back.
[ Laughter ]
It's an expensive game.
Uh,
but you're different.
Uh, first of all,
each of those two businesses
was headed by,
uh, one dynamic entrepreneur.
Here, I get three
for the price of one.
Not bad.
[ Laughs ]
And to your great credit, uh,
you're enormously disciplined,
and you have
high energy.
It's obvious how ‐‐
how you feel about your product.
Um, so, I'm very much inclined
to go into the deal.
Okay?
Herjavec: Ooh!
Except one
little problem.
Ooh.
♪♪
Narrator:
One Shark is out.
Barbara seems interested
in the DeCicco brothers'
protein‐enhanced coffee drink,
Sunniva, but there's an issue.
I'm very much inclined
to go into the deal.
Okay?
Herjavec: Ooh!
Except one
little problem.
Ooh.
I want to take my pen
and keep scraping my tongue
'cause I keep having
that aftertaste,
and I've been
sipping my water,
trying to get that
out of my mouth,
and it seems like
every time I sip the water,
that creamy,
not likable ‐‐
sorry ‐‐ taste
gets enhanced all over
and I go back
to square one.
I think
when it comes down to a drink,
the most important quality
is how I respond to the taste,
and for that
one little reason alone,
I have to pass.
You're wonderful guys,
though.
I'm out.
Cuban:
Look, guys.
You've got a great name
that's eye‐catching
and will
make people interested.
You've got
a competitive price.
You're the lowest cost provider
in this category.
All those things
are great.
But the more success you have,
the more expensive it becomes
to turn this into a profitable
and a sellable company.
I ‐‐ I'm just not ready
to make
a $10, $25, or $50 million
investment in this category,
so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you.
Before we get
to you guys,
I just want to say
we have the manufacturing.
We have
the distribution.
We have the product,
the team in place.
And you said that,
clearly, yeah.
Jimmy: Right,
but what we don't have
is ‐‐ is the influence,
and that's why we're here.
We're at the tipping point
of this thing.
We've come so far
from this dorm room,
and we want to share it
with America.
Guys, you ever
heard the saying,
"The dream is free but
the hustle is sold separately"?
Well, you guys
have the hustle,
and I love that.
You have
a smart idea.
I think
it's right on trend.
But my concern ‐‐
it's a high valuation.
At the moment,
I have to be out.
♪♪
So, guys, I want to commend you
on recognizing the shift
that's happening in the food
and beverage industry today.
A lot of the big products
on shelves are high sugar,
high carbs,
high fructose corn syrup.
They're really
not that good for you.
And you guys have recognized
a shift that's happening,
which is high protein,
high good fats, low sugar.
That's where
this product is going, so I'm ‐‐
I'm thumbs‐up with you
on that.
I'm also really impressed
with your velocity.
Guys,
beverages are expensive.
When beverages do well
and everyone sees
the billion‐dollar exits
and they get very excited,
they don't see the graveyard
of hundreds of beverages
that have all raised
a ton of money
and are no longer
around today.
Beverages need millions
of dollars for it to thrive.
When I got involved
with Bulletproof,
we put in
$10 million then.
And the reason is, it's the ‐‐
it's the route to market.
You've got to go from you guys
to a distributor.
The distributor has got to
go to a retailer.
Everyone is carrying and lugging
heavy boxes full of liquid,
and everyone needs their margins
along the way.
I think that
the amount you're raising
is insufficient in the
beverage space to go into it.
But I think for me,
the biggest thing
that I bring in
when I decide
whether to go into a brand
or not is the taste.
The product has to punch me
and go, "Wow,"
and you need
to work on that.
I'm out.
Congrats, guys.
Appreciate it.
All right, guys,
thank you.
Good luck, you guys.
Thank you.
♪♪
At the end of the day,
I'm doing this
with my two little brothers.
It's ‐‐ It's love. It's trust.
It's hustle.
It's competition,
and no coach, no Shark, no boss
can tell us otherwise
because we know
what we're set out to do,
and we're
gonna go do it.
I really wish
I could've got a deal.
I was counting on you,
big shot.
You know,
I would've.
I'm ready to ‐‐ I mean, but ‐‐
and I'll put more in.
But I need something
that when I throw it down,
I'm like, "Wow."
♪♪